If you're a gamer, you probably still have
some of your games for various Nintendo consoles
stashed away in your closet, along with your
Lisa Frank Trapper Keeper or your old Transformers.
Parting with these classics could earn some
cold hard cash—for the right titles, of
course.
These price estimates are based on video game
price charting sites and recent eBay auctions,
and focus only on games that have been used.
If you kept your games sealed in their original
boxes, you were probably a really boring kid...but
obviously sealed games are worth a whole lot
more.
So, what’s worth the most today?
Bonk's Adventure
Originally released for the doomed TurboGrafx-16
console, Bonk's Adventure’s developers ported
this quirky 2D platformer to the NES in 1994.
In the game, you control Bonk, a hard-headed
caveboy who battles prehistoric enemies by
literally head-butting them to death.
If you've got a copy of Bonk's Adventure for
the NES hiding in your collection, it's worth
quite a few bones—about $400 for the cartridge.
Bubble Bobble Part 2
The second installment in the Bubble Bobble
series sees the return of Bub and Bob, a pair
of humans-turned-dragons who must make their
way through increasingly difficult stages
by barfing out bubbles to trap their enemies.
The gameplay is similar to other Bubble Bobble
games, although the NES version also includes
bonus stages, in case you ever wanted to play
bubble dragon volleyball, which probably isn’t
a euphemism.
A Bubble Bobble Part 2 cartridge is worth
approximately $300.
Panic Restaurant
It’s a literal food fight when Chef Cookie
has to battle his way through six levels filled
with food-beasts, with nothing but a frying
pan and a stylish mustache.
The game features some of the most seriously
deranged box art of all time, but even if
you've only got a loose copy of Panic Restaurant,
it's worth around $540...or one night with
Gordon Ramsay.
Aero Fighters
Games where you pilot fighter planes are a
dime a dozen, but Aero Fighters stands out
by being one of the rarest titles ever released
for Super NES.
Though its gameplay is predictable and critics
of the day called this version mediocre, the
once-worthless cart became desirable simply
because there aren’t too many of them out
there.
This one comes in at $559 for the cartridge
alone...but you probably won’t want to waste
too much time playing it.
Hagane: The Final Conflict
A side-scrolling action platformer for the
Super NIntendo featuring a cyborg ninja on
a revenge quest?
If you’re not already completely sold on
Hagane: The Final Conflict, it’s time to
put your inner child on a milk carton, because
it’s missing.
With a futuristic setting, challenging stages,
and advanced controls, Hagane has become a
cult classic.
Currently, you could get around $475 for a
loose cartridge.
Metal Warriors
Stomp down puny humans, smash through walls,
and blast giant robots while piloting a mech
assault suit in the Super Nintendo game Metal
Warriors.
It's set in a dystopian future where the remaining
"Metal Warriors" defend the earth from the
evil Dark Axis forces.
If you've got a copy, it can fetch you about
$200, or about one one-millionth of the cost
to buy a robot death machine of your very
own.
Worms: Armageddon
You control a team of angry worms in this
turn-based military strategy game for the
Nintendo 64.
As you advance through your annelid enemies,
you can upgrade and gain new weapons, including
the "Holy Hand Grenade" from the film Monty
Python and the Holy Grail.
Currently, the game is worth approximately
$200, or twenty-five pounds of nightcrawlers.
Bomberman 64: The Second Attack
In this sequel to Bomberman 64, you control
Bomberman on an action adventure to save the
world from possessed knights, demons, and
even a goddess.
While the game does not have graphics on par
with some of the other N64 titles of its era,
Bomberman 64: The Second Attack does give
Bomberman a backstory...if you really want
a complex history of a guy who’s mostly
fun because he blows stuff up.
You can sell this game for about $150.
Cubivore: Survival of the Fittest
Cubivore is an action-adventure title where
you must guide your floppy, cubic avatar through
the world and make it stronger by devouring
other cubivores...or, strangely enough, mating
with them in the game’s convenient “love
tunnel.”
You absorb their power or make more powerful
babies, and you remorselessly consume and
impregnate your fellow creatures until you
can take on the big boss, Killer Cubivore.
Cubivore can net you about $130 for the Gamecube
disc alone, or about the price of a visit
to a real love tunnel.
Shantae
The first in the Shantae series of platformers,
you guide Shantae, a half-genie, on her fight
against a dastardly female pirate with a terrible
name, Risky Boots.
The series has been wildly popular since its
first release in 2002, with a fourth installment
in the series set to be released in late 2016.
If you're lucky enough to have wished for
a copy for the Gameboy Color handheld console,
you could sell the cartridge today for $290.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
valuable games you’ve found in your closet….